et
notre invité politique ce matin cette
erreur tout l'enjeu merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et eric woerth vous
êtes président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
soutient d'emmanuel macro on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes fois
d'interviews en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par
creissels bertron du groupe la dépêche
bonjour cristal jorian mot j'aurais
également
exact on voit c'est un duel à distance
qui s'est installé depuis deux jours
entre marine le pen et emmanuel macron
qui sont chacun sur le terrain et qui
s'affrontent par par phrase j'ai envie
de dire parfois assez forte on va y
revenir mais d'abord je voudrais faire
injure à ce qu'elle dit clément bonne
hier et mambo le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes qui dit nous avons
une responsabilité dans le fait qu'il y
ait une extrême droite forte est-ce que
vous reconnaissez une part de
responsabilité toutefois le wifo tout le
monde a une responsabilité dans le fait
que la france puisse demain pendant dix
jours basculer dans l'extrême droite qui
a beaucoup de conséquences pour ouvrir
les yeux sur ce que ça veut dire ça veut
pas dire diaboliser les gens mais ça
veut dire juste dire quelles seront les
conséquences d'une politique d'extrême
droite pour le pour le pays
de nicolas sarkozy qui lui même avait
quand même réussi à peu près à faire
baisser un moment donné fin de tout le
monde a une part de responsabilité mais
je vais vous dire c'est c'est la société
elle-même qui produit ça on est dans une
société de plus en plus complexe on est
dans une société assez brutal on est
dans une société assez inquiète la
france en plus c'est une particularité
c'est qu'elle avait un chômage de masse
qui est en train de baisser très très
puissamment depuis maintenant les deux
dernières années et s'est taillé une
bonne nouvelle est que tous à temps les
choses et donne au fond un peu plus
d'écho à la parole de la démagogie et du
simplisme la démagogie ça veut dire
aussi quelque chose ça veut dire qu'on
sait pas trop comment on fera mais on
dit ce que les gens veulent entendre et
puis finalement un moment donné on a
envie d'y croire et puis et puis on a
envie de renverser la table on sait pas
que quand on renverse la table souvent
la première assiette concas c'est la
vôtre alors merci comme ça que ça
fonctionne marine le pen accuse emmanuel
macron d'avoir dégradé la protection
sociale elle dit que son projet
aujourd'hui un projet de casse sociale
est ce que c'est ça qui lui donne du
grain à moudre marine ce qu'il aurait dû
en faire plus en matière de protection
sociale dans ce quinquennat il aurait
fait beaucoup enfin la protection
sociale c'est la protection notamment
pendant toute la période de crise c'est
pas deux mois la crise la crise du coc
vide c'est plus plus les gilet jaune
c'est quasiment deux ans et demi trois
ans c'est quelqu'un qui répond ainsi
quand une situation exceptionnelle faut
être capable de répondre ponctuellement
je veux dire ponctuellement ça veut dire
que quand votre commerce va fermer que
votre contrat va être rompu et que vous
ne retrouverez pas travail après il faut
évidemment prendre des mesures
extrêmement fortes et toutes les mesures
d'activité partielle de dead aux
entreprises de de prêts garantis toutes
ces mesures qui qui ont tord ont permis
à la france de deux de survivre à cette
crise et de redémarrer d'ailleurs
jusqu'à l'ukraine parce que l'ukraine
est une crise autre nom il un travail
d'écouté et un travail social tout à
fait enfin honnêtement tout à fait
remarquable personnes défendu les
français il
suffit juste de regarder en face mais il
a fallu la crise pour qu'ils fassent ça
est ce qu'il aurait dû le faire sur
l'ensemble des canons mais mais mais
veut pas à pas à ce niveau là mais qu'on
est une vie de femme on a une vision
sociale est
très forte en france on a un système
pour mettre un pays qui redistribue
énormément jamais suffisamment mais de
façon énorme est en réalité la meilleure
manière d'aider tous nos compatriotes
qui ont plein de plein de problèmes
sociaux à un moment donné et puis moi un
autre enfin c'est d'avoir des modèles
sociaux de plus en plus précis aider les
gens exactement dans le les difficultés
qu'ils ont et puis surtout c'est le taux
d'emploi dire de faire en sorte que
chacun un moment donné puisse trouver le
travail au travers de la formation au
travers de la croissance au travers de
tout cela est au fond c'est quand même
le seul projet qui doit qui doit nous
nous occuper c'est de savoir comment la
france elle va dans les années qui
viennent générer de la croissance et en
sorte que les personnes puissent être
mieux employé que le taux d'emploi
un
sujet pendant sept ans à un sujet
d'inquiétude pour les français lors
exercer le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
et la croûte d'en faire plus là dessus
mais il en a fait énormément ils à
protéger le pouvoir d'achat comme jamais
on est une récession de 8 ou 9% c'est
parce qu on s'aperçoit ce que ça veut
dire 8 ou 9% de récession alors que le
chômage alors que le pouvoir d'achat
était totalement protégée il était le
bouclier de pouvoir d'achat a été tout à
fait considérable et après avec cette
crise en ukraine avec l'augmentation
massive des prix avec l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie un autre bouclier a
été posée un bouclier sur le prix de
l'électricité sur le prix du gaz à la
réduction des prix d'augmentation de
deux adolescents c'est colossal ces 25
milliards c'est bien plus que ce que
madame le pen peut dire quand elle à
madame le pen s'agite pour dire il faut
baisser la tva c'est une plaisanterie
baisser la tva ça sert à quoi les impôts
aujourd'hui sorti en a trop pour tout le
monde mais ça sert à quoi ça sert à
payer les services publics est ce que
madame le pen elle veut réduire les
services publics sur l'ensemble du pays
jan janssen tout cas
contre la fraude par une lutte contre
l'immigration effacer ces deux c'est de
l'argent factice ça n'existe pas on peut
toujours le croire on peut mettre un
bulletin de madame le pen dans une urne
et puis après on verra bien on peut
jouer à la roulette russe avec l'avenir
du pays c'est quand même cela dont il
s'agit c'est pas sérieux si vous baissez
la tva c'est le seul un beau fond global
si vous baissez la tva à un moment donné
vous aurez moins d'argent dans les
caisses de l'état vous aurez moins la
possibilité de d'avoir des services
publics organisés au plus proche des
français mais ses services publics ils
ont besoin de plus d'efficacité la
dépense publique elle a besoin d'être
plus efficace tous ces sujets sont
fondamentaux i la lutte contre la fraude
mais tout le monde à lutter contre la
fraude il faut lutter contre la fraude
c'est très important de lutter contre la
fraude va chaque fois qu'on sait pas
comment financer un projet on met lutte
contre la fraude égale exactement la
somme qu'on a envie d'atteindre donc
tout ça c'est de l'argent factice eric
woerth un ventirad henin hier
a strasbourg à mulhouse le président
candidat a été interpellé sur le pouvoir
d'achat on voit que c'est ça qui
préoccupe aujourd'hui les français
est-ce qu'il peut aller plus loin dans
les aides et bien sûr qu'on peut aller
plus loin on peut aller plus loin
d'abord ponctuellement il ya des
problèmes sur l'alimentaire il faut
certainement alimentaire ils sont au
président de le dire et c'est aux
candidats de le dire en tout cas on peut
sans doute aller plus loin sur des
sujets
il faut probablement aidé un peu plus
les français où certains français à un
moment donné dans le domaine de
l'alimentaire tout cela a été fait
emmanuel macron il a fait le déchet
qu'un chèque inflation il a baissé le
prix de l'essence en baissant fond la
facture de l'essence il a installé un
bouclier c'est à dire cela heureusement
un plafonnement du prix de l'énergie
donc litas a été terriblement rendez
vous enfin c'était je sais bien qu'une
fois que une fois que la chose est
présenté et il présentait elle est allée
manger les digérer on passe à autre
chose la question n'est pas aussi simple
que cela on doit évidemment reconnaître
cela à la fois la protection du pouvoir
d'achat des français c'est emmanuel
macron sauf que lui il prouve madame le
pen elle a jamais rien géré elle a juste
gérer des partis politiques juste gérer
des partis politiques dont elle a hérité
donc je moi je veux bien que dans un
pays qui va être soumis à une des défis
fondamentaux comment assurer le défi
écologique il est fondamental comment
assurer le défi numérique comment
essayer d'avoir une transition sociale
qui permette que personne ne soit
laissé au bord de la route de ces
différentes transitions tous ces sujets
ils sont considérables les sujets
géopolitique l'extension des empires
l'envi les prédateurs comme la russie
qui visiblement ont très envie de bouger
et de commencer à tuer les démocraties
tout autour d'elle qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment on fait ce qu'on veut moins
d'europe est-ce qu'on veut moins de
compétitivité du pays et ce qu'on veut
moins de travail est-ce qu'on veut
distribuer du pouvoir d'achat gratuit
tout ça se retournera de façon
fondamentale contre la france une
politique d'appauvrissement de la france
marine le pen emmanuel macron c'est une
politique d'ouverture du pays
d'ouverture du pays pour le pouvoir
d'achat pour l'emploi plus d'europe on a
besoin de plus d'europe comment peut-on
aller d'ailleurs les locaux vont ils les
d'hier et je crois qu'il a raison cette
élection c'est aussi une forme de
référendum pour l'europe est ce qu'on a
envie est ce qu'on considère qu'on doit
être tout seul dans le monde entier
comme le voudraient madame le pen est
elle le fera dès le mois de délai des si
elle est élue dès son élection puisque
l'étoile serait selon la présidente de
l'europe elle se fâcherait à peu près
avec tous les dirigeants européens dans
le dirigeant allemand dont elle dit pis
que pan et puis elle se s'accordera
monsieur poutine parce qu'elle l'a dit
et qu'elle l'a écrit et à ce moment là
qu'est ce qu'on fait on constate l'échec
de l'europe on constate que la france
travaille avec la hongrie et la pologne
c'est à dire de démocratie il libéral
c'est dire dans laquelle on réduit les
libertés parce que le front national il
a besoin d'expliquer l'inexplicable
et pour expliquer l'inexplicable à un
moment donné au bout d'un certain temps
on muselle la presse on vous muselle au
musée la liberté d'expression c'est
impossible non on croit toujours que
c'est impossible on pense que cela dit
d'elle à la diabolisation c'est pas de
la diabolisation ça existe en europe
c'est le cas de monsieur or bad c'est
qu'à la pologne
sujet sur lequel le candidat était
interpellé avant-hier et hier lors de
ses déplacements c'est la réforme des
retraites il a été tellement interpellé
qu'il a reculé sur certains paramètres
notamment l'âge accepté peut-être
d'étaler cette retraite cette réforme
pardon dans le temps de la soumettre à
référendum qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces de ces trois propositions qu'il fait
un petit peu a brûlé on est alors bien
pourquoi on est dans une élection ça
s'appelle être à brûle pourpoint on a eu
un premier tour un premier tour de que
que dans les manuels matheron à mâcon a
gagné
assez de quatre points derrière il ya
quand même un bloc d extrémisme de
droite extrêmement extrêmement fort et
si on ajoute monsieur mélenchon qui
n'est pas compatible avec heureusement
il l'a dit avec l'extrémisme de droite
on a un blog protestataires extrêmement
fort renverser la table
l'histoire de la retraite s'est
cristallisée mais au fond qu'est ce
qu'on veut et un moment donné aussi
est-ce qu'on a un régime par répartition
tout le monde dit bravo je suis d'accord
pour le régime par répartition tout le
monde dit je veux pas partir plus tard
je vis plus tard en bonne santé
contrairement à tout ce qu'on voit dans
toutes les polémiques tous n'ont pas
tout le monde enfin globalement la laine
en moyenne dans la société française on
vit en bonne santé un peu plus longtemps
donc on va doit partager un moment donné
se tendre travailler un peu plus
longtemps et puis également vivre un peu
plus longtemps alors à
l'arrivée pas un recul arrêter de
présenter de caricaturer à force vous
allez finir par faire élire l'extrême
droite a caricaturé les propositions
ce n'est en aucun cas un recul vous
pouvez tenir compte du premier tour et
vous dire comment ici de faire en sorte
pour que cette cette réforme qui était
la réforme d'un modèle qui est au coeur
du modèle social tout le monde est
concerné les actifs parce qu'ils payent
les retraites évidemment les retraités
parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie de voir
leur retraite baissé ça veut dire qu'il
finit les actifs ils doivent pas être
maltraités par rapport aux retraités
parce que sinon ils ont jamais plus de 2
de retraite et vous une augmentation de
l'âge avec nicolas sarkozy en est passé
à 62 ans et on peut pas avoir de la
brutalité il dort dans ce cadre là il
faut expliquer aux gens et expliquer le
régime par répartition expliquer ce
qu'il n'aurait pas dû
65 ans en 2030 2031 c'est bien au delà
de son mandat il peut expliquer que et
d'ailleurs il expliqué peut dire moi je
vais bien
ce qu'on fera jusqu'à la fin de mon
mandat jusqu'à la fin de son mandat on
est à 63 ans et demi qu'il est entré
côté sedan prochaine mais pas du tout
mais pas du tout je vais aller en aucun
cas la fin le président il peut dire je
projette à 10 ans à 15 ans pour le faire
à 20 ans la projection vous pouvez faire
à 10 ans si vous voulez il n'y a pas de
yade c'est une augmentation progressive
de l'âge de la retraite très progressive
bon vous pouvez aussi président d'ibm
ont peu changé on peut évidemment termes
de calendrier je peux m'engager
jusqu'en 2027 sicile et
c est bien ça aboutit à 63 ans et demi
quoi grosso modo et puis après au
président qui arrive de faire le point
et de regarder où on en est de regarder
si la société peut l'accepter de
regarder si la pénibilité est quelque
chose qui fonctionne c'est à dire les
gens usés pardon du terme prématurément
par leur activité par leur activité
professionnelle ils peuvent partir plus
tôt et c'est très très important que ce
soit le cas mais pour être juste faut
pouvoir le constater l'évidence est
inéquitable par rapport à ceux qui
partent un peu plus tard vous savez tous
les autres pays la belgique l'italie
l'allemagne et états qui ne sont pas des
pays dans lequel on vit un enfer travail
évidemment plus longtemps ceux qui ont
commencé plus tôt ils doivent pouvoir
partir aussi plutôt tout sa
trajectoire alors pourquoi ne pas
assumer de dire mais oui il va falloir
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans pour un
moment donné un jour on travaillera
jusqu'à 65 ans ce jour dans ce jour ça
peut être en 2030 en 2031 si on veut si
on veut si on considère qu'on peut aller
plus loin on peut considérer qu'on ne
décale de trois ans de 4 enfin il vous
savez non médias mais je comprends pas
vous êtes allés jusqu'à 62 ans il aurait
pu aller jusqu'à 63 ans est toujours un
non plus mais peut-être on aurait pu
aller jusqu'à 63 points
62 ans vous allez à un moment donné vous
poser la question de la 63e et 63e année
c'est un engagement très fort parce que
sinon sinon il ya plus de régime des
retraites madame madame le pen est
grosso modo 10 62 elle a toujours une
réforme des retraites de retard elle
était archi contrôlée 62 ans elle
voulait 60 ans la dernière fois
maintenant elle dit oui 62 gens avec
beaucoup d'exceptions quand même donc ça
coûte 25 milliards ces exceptions quand
même donc c'est aux frais des actifs
donc on va augmenter les cotisations
sociales des français les actifs la
personne qui est en activité aujourd'hui
et qui paye à et qu'il ya un petit
salaire et on y verra ses cotisations
retraite augmenter pour financer
les revenus des retraités en face tu
enfin écoutez écoutez moi j'ai rencontré
un jour madame le pen quand j'ai réalisé
cette réforme avec nicolas sarkozy il ya
une dizaine d'années elle savait même
pas ce que c'était que le régime par
répartition donc est probablement l a
fait des progrès enfin on peut pas
confier non plus les clés de la france
c'est trop sérieux c'est d'abord celle
adamence l'argent des français d'abord
c'est la solidarité qui est notre modèle
de fond ça nécessite une efficacité ça
nécessite de la responsabilité c'est
difficile le pays va être confronté à
des murs d'investissements considérables
et probablement net à la veille d'une
vraie révolution comme l'a été la
révolution industrielle qui va changer
nos modes de vie on peut pas se payer le
luxe d'une présidence basé sur la
démagogie c'est juste pas possible après
les français font ce qu'ils voudront
c'est pas de la diabolisation mais c'est
comme ça le point d'achat payer a payé
par tous les français de façon factice
sans se poser la question de savoir si
le pouvoir d'achat n'est pas la
résultante du taux d'emploi est la
résultante du travail du travail c'est
une bannière évidemment très mensongères
de dire les choses aux enfants dernière
question sur les retraites emmanuel
macron lors de son déplacement a dit que
le projet pourrait être soumis à
référendum vous nous dites aujourd'hui
il ira au bout s'il ya référendum ça
veut dire que c'est laissé à
l'appréciation des fruits mais aller au
bout ça veut dire présentée jusqu'au
bout les éléments qui permettent la
décision parce que sinon c'est où le
parlement ou le référendum enfin moi je
crois que
mais pourquoi pas sur un sujet comme
celui là qui est au coeur de notre
système de justice sociale parce que
tout le monde encore une fois est
concerné on peut pas le laisser aller à
vau l'eau nicolas sarkozy ne l'a pas
fait et emmanuel macron ne veut pas le
faire c'est un devoir de président de la
république sauver l'espèce pas sauvés
mais faire en sorte que le système par
répartition soit soit soit équilibré sur
le plan financier
évidemment il est à 10 milliards d'euros
de déficit en ce moment et puis
l'augmentation dans le temps va hélas le
temps passant ça va évidemment augmenter
donc vous ne pouvez pas laisser au fond
aux marchés financiers à ceux qui
prêtent à la france vous ne pouvez pas
leur laisser la possibilité de d'être
les garants du paiement des retraites
des français on peut pas dire je vais de
la souveraineté je veux l'autonomie je
veux de la dépendance et lycées laissez
les prêteurs qui prête à la france le
soin de financer le régime de retraite
le régime de retraite qui doit être
équilibrée parce qu'on le doit à nos
jeunes moi je veux bien qu'on parle sans
arrêt de justice et j'y suis
profondément attaché il n'y a pas la
justice uniquement pour lundi matin et
puis après après on s'en moque il ya la
justice entre les générations il n'y a
rien de plus cher que nos propres
enfants
voilà on partage tout ça et heureusement
et donc on peut pas laisser à nos
enfants des lettres qu'ils n'ont pas à
payer donc c'est normal de revoir le
régime de retraite c'est courageux
d'ailleurs de le faire à un moment donné
aussi aussi fort que cela alors parlons
un peu de politique eric woerth nicolas
sarkozy hier à apporter son soutien au
candidat emmanuel macron à leur ont dit
que emmanuel macron va devoir récupérer
les votes par exemple des électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon est ce que c'est un
bon signal que ce soutien de nicolas
sarkozy mais évidemment enfin je vais
vous présenter toute manière négative
c'est très très bien que nicolas sarkozy
c'est mieux que nicolas sarkozy soutient
emmanuel mâcon qui ne le soutiennent pas
nicolas sarkozy si un homme
qui aurait quitté un excellent président
de la république très très
très appréciée à droite et je
non je crois pas enfin je ne crois pas
donc nicolas sarkozy c'est une vraie
parole il a dit
il est sifflé par quatre personnes dans
un meeting et les républicains qui font
4% donc jeu nettement vous pouvez tous
présentés mais enfin comme ça mais moi
je préférais de confronter à la vraie
réalité c'est que in fine et nicolas
sarkozy ça a été le patron de la droite
c'est quelqu'un qui est profondément
social qui voit là sa parole elle compte
est ici tant mieux mais elle vient
s'additionner avec d'autres paroles avec
des gens qui sont en plus à gauche s'est
laissée en fait c'est la marque de
fabrique des manuels macron de dire il
ya au fond des sociaux-démocrates et des
des gaullistes libéraux comme moi qui
ont envie de participer à un moment
donné à la construction d'une france une
france différente d'une france nouvelle
devant l'ensemble des défis qui nous est
en jeu
il faut il faut évidemment forme une
coalition où quelqu un qu importe c'est
une coalition une coalition ça veut dire
de deux de casser les clivages on nous a
toujours dit j'ai pendant dix actions
menez
vous écoutez pas la gauche votent à
gauche vous écoutait pas la droite y en
a ras-le-bol il faut casser le cruiser
est ce que ça veut dire qu'en face ils
me posaient des rafale de questions je
peux pas répondre donc oui il faut
évidemment qu'est l'islam emmanuel
macron il a réussi à faire cela il a
réussi à le faire non pas en détruisant
la démocratie française mais je pense en
approfondissant la démocratie française
et cet approfondissement niveau un
moment donné qu'on puisse discuter avec
tous ceux qui pensent dans le champ
républicain que la france est une france
de progrès et que l'europe est une
solution pour la france et que le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la résultante du
travail et ses héros font là dessus on
doit tenir et que notre modèle social il
faut le défendre coûte que coûte son
modèle social il faut aussi améliorer
pour mieux pour mieux tenir compte des
difficultés de chacun et que ça pète
uniquement un modèle social parapluie
qui englobe tout le monde n'importe
comment et qui n'aide au fond pas bien
les gens il faut aider les français est
ce que ça veut dire qu'un groupe l air
pour y intégrer la majorité à l'issue
des oui pourquoi pas pourquoi donc
pourquoi ne pas le faire
ton point de vue est ce que pour vous
les lr douar vous doivent rester tel
quel il ya un pacte de gouvernement
entre l air jlr à 4% comme voulzy
journée à la veille d'un deuxième tour
la france peut que je voulais déjà dire
le basculer à l'extrême droite donc la
question elle est de gagner et puis
après d'avoir évidemment une vision plus
unitaire qui peut parler de l'équipe qui
pourrait dire il faut être moins
rassemblé faut être plus rassemblée
autour des idées et autour du programme
qu'elles résident sans doute d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas un programme enrichi comme
il le dit ça veut dire en écoutant aussi
ce qui a été dit par ailleurs et puis
travailler se retrousser les manches et
travailler
en fait c'est pas le sujet
pour la dernière quatre et demi je suis
pas sûr qu'on compte sur vivent un parti
qui n'a ni leader ni idées il sert à
rien donc il par contre les idées les
idées et les valeurs des républicains
doivent évidemment perdurer sous
d'autres formes et c'est pas la première
fois dans la nation et moi je suis à
droite je suis de droite libérale de
droite sociale et cette droite là
évidemment elle existait au sein de l
air elle doit constituer elle a continué
à exister et l air ne peut pas se
comptent 2 peut pas se contenter me
semble-t-il dans la gravité la situation
dans laquelle on est ne peut pas se
contenter uniquement de dire faites
comme vous voulez
je votais pas pour madame le pen mais
enfin je n'appelle pas à voter monsieur
mâcon parce que je n'aime pas et une
sorte de sentiment comme ça incroyable
sont pas sérieux enfin c'est pas sérieux
que monsieur mélenchon le disent bravo
chapeau parce que c'est mais mais enfin
pas l air que lr s'engage on peut pas l
aps les leurs ne peuvent pas les ce
n'est pas un observateur de la vie
politique ait l'air ne peut pas
uniquement dire bah oui c'est pas mal je
ne le savais pas madame le pen est élue
le lundi d'après le matin et l'air va
dire ah mais je ne savais pas que
l'erreur je ne savais pas je n'avais pas
remarqué non il faut s'engager pas
uniquement par tweet c'est très très
bien la résistance à la à l'extrême
droite par tweet c est très fort c'est
très courageux enfin ça demande plus que
ça ça demande un engagement à un moment
donné démocratique vraiment ça veut pas
dire piétiner sa propre identité ça veut
pas dire oublier d'où on vient enfin le
général de gaulle où jacques chirac
doivent se retourner dans leur tombe
quand ils voient une attitude aussi
ambiguë nous ne sommes plus en 2017 nous
sommes en 2022 est ce que la future
majorité doit discuter avec votre ancien
parti politique les républicains en vue
des législatives
considérant ce que vous venez de deals
tout le monde doit discuter enfin se
discute même si le pourquoi pas mais
pourquoi pas les français je pense
qu'ils attendent est ce que les
politiques ne se chamaillent pas tout le
temps sur des détails dans le projet de
2 des manuels macron il ya beaucoup de
choses que l air avait elle-même dit
d'ailleurs on adèle madame pécresse
disait que c'était du copier coller donc
il ya un moment donné on peut quand même
se retrouver sur un projet de
gouvernement avec un président de la
république évidemment élu légitime et
qui est également un projet qui a été
présenté devant les français à partir de
là tous les champs sont ouverts pour
aider à la réforme de notre pays ça veut
pas dire n'importe comment en réhaussant
notamment l'intervention de tous les
corps intermédiaires ou l'école
institutionnelle en réussissant par
exemple le rôle du parlement dernière
question puisqu'elle ne resterai pas
tant voteraient oui je serai candidat
aux législatives sous quelle étiquette
mais je fous le seul de la majorité
présidentielle évidemment merci beaucoup
et reaper merci d'avoir été notre invité
merci creissels à la une de la dépêche
c'est la réforme des retraites retraite
c'est de la dynamite c'est à la une de
votre journal
[Musique]